in a time of divided politics it was a
rare but touching sight of unity
the prime minister and the leader of the
opposition laying flowers at the scene
of the attack
in his tribute boris johnson wrote to
the memory of a fine parliamentarian and
much-loved colleague he was a man of the
people he was absolutely there for
everyone he was a much-loved
parliamentarian
to me he was a dear and loyal friend but
also he was a devoted husband and father
and we think of julia and their children
at this really sad time they're in our
thoughts sir david amis was an
enormously popular mp he was also a
loving husband and father of five
this picture was taken a few weeks ago
at his daughter alexandra's wedding
and in the community he was also known
as a man of great faith this holy
celebration of the mass will be offered
for
our
beloved parishioner
sir david amis
we're all saddened
shocked
because this man is so dear to everyone
at the catholic church where he
worshipped a mass was held in his memory
father alex poblodor and many in the
congregation were his friends
the shock at what happened is still raw
and people are finding it hard to
understand why such a kind man was
targeted
i just hope and pray that
together with the community
they will also be able to accept this
as something that
cannot be forgotten
amidst all the grief there is a fast
moving police investigation a 25 year
old man remains in custody and officers
are not looking for any other suspects
the incident is being treated as an act
of terrorism
forensic officers are still working
inside the church where the attack took
place whilst he was holding a
constituency surgery now the murder has
provoked a huge outpouring of grief on
both sides of the police cord and many
people have been laying tributes this
one down here is typical of what so many
people have been saying it reads may god
embrace you now as you look down on the
town you were so proud to represent
and across south end flags are lowered
as a mark of respect
an mp for 38 years sir david's impact
has been huge on this constituency i
think it's safe to say we're a community
and grieving today councillor alex
bright a friend and colleague told me
the loss has cast a long shadow over
this seaside town he was missed the
south end i think is probably the best
way to put it i've known sir david since
i was 13.
he has always been a constant here in
south end not just for me but for
everybody here and in the conservative
party here in south end
the nature of this attack is
intensifying the debate over the safety
of mps the home secretary is ordering an
urgent review
but for now many people here just want
to remember and grieve a kind and decent
man who touched so many lives
alex rossi sky news
leon c